yo Chris hey man what's up not much so
much how's your weekend um I know you
don't really care you're just asking so
I asked you about your weekend
everybody knows you went snowboarding
bro it's all over Instagram go easy on
the hashtags what about you how was
yours
oh yeah it was cool man you know
snowboard up in mana fresh pow-pow dope
yeah check it out you guys talking about
the weekend Nana sounds fun actually
went to Disney on Ice on Saturday this
guy you always tries to relate to you
and be your friend at the end of the day
still got a job to do anyway
I need 20 copies of this from you
stapled and collated to the meeting
later okay sure
all right copy Chris hey
what the hell is your name I'll say it
starts with a J Josh Jamie I still have
to go make copies for Shane's meeting
later so stapled and collated oh yeah
pretty much
okay have a good one dude peace bro
should really remember his name crap did
you see me staring hey making copies oh
yeah he seems so tired
yeah I'm gonna get some coffees you
think you're tired I'm exhausted I've
been planning Dan's party all week here
is the planner constantly inviting you
and your co-workers out for drinks food
a movie but whatever it is you always
come up with an excuse see you guys
what are you thinking about I don't know
I'm just glad I have someone to talk to
you I guess yeah same what nothing